so on the day after the brexit vote in
June 2016 when Britain woke up to the
shock of discovering that we were
leaving the European Union my editor at
The Observer newspaper in the UK asked
me to go back to South Wales where I
grew up and to write a report and so I
went to a town called Abbey Vale here it
is
it's in the South Wales Valleys which is
this quite special place it's always had
this very sort of rich working class
culture and it's famous for its Welsh
male voice choirs in rugby and it's cold
but when I was a teenager the coal mines
and the steelworks closed and the entire
area was devastated and I went there
because it had one of the highest leave
votes in the country 62% of the people
here voted to leave the European Union
and I wanted to know why when I got
there I was just a bit taken aback
because the last time I went to ever
Vale it looks like this and now it looks
like this this is a new 33 million pound
College a further education that was
mostly funded by the European Union and
this is the new Sports Centre that set
the middle of a 350 million pound
regeneration project that is being
funded by the European Union and this is
the new 77 million pound Road
improvement scheme and there's a new
train line the new railway station
they're all being funded by the European
Union and it's not as if any of this is
a secret because there's big signs like
this everywhere I had this sort of weird
sense of unreality walking around the
town and it came to a head when I met
this young young man in front of the
Sports Centre and he told me that he had
voted to leave because the European
Union
had done nothing for him he was fed up
with it and all around town people told
me the same thing they said that they
wanted to take back control which was
one of the slogans in the campaign and
they told me that they were most fed up
with the immigrants and with the
refugees that had enough which was odd
because walking around I didn't meet any
immigrants or refugees
I met one Polish woman who told me she
was practically the only foreigner in
town and when I checked the figures I
discovered that every Bell actually has
one of the lowest rates of immigration
in the country and so I was just a bit
baffled because I couldn't really
understand with people getting their
information from because it was the
right-wing tabloid newspapers which
printed all these stories about
immigration and this is a very much a
left-wing labor stronghold but then
after the article came out this woman
got in touch with me and she was from
everywhere and she told me about all
this stuff that she'd seen on Facebook I
was like what stuff and she said there's
all this quite scary stuff about
immigration especially about Turkey so I
tried to find it but there was nothing
there because there's no archive of ads
that people see or what had been pushed
into their news feeds no trace of
anything we've gone completely dark and
this referendum that will have this
profound effect forever on Britain it's
already had a profound effect the
Japanese car manufacturers that came to
Wales and the Northeast to replace the
mining jobs they're already going
because of brexit and this entire
referendum took place in darkness
because it took place on Facebook and
what happens on Facebook stays on
Facebook because only you see your
newsfeed and then it vanishes so it's
impossible to research anything so we
have no idea who saw what ads or what
impact they had or what data was used to
target these people or even who placed
the ads or how much money was spent
or even what nationality
they were but Facebook does Facebook has
these answers and it's refused to give
them to us our Parliament has asked Mark
Zuckerberg multiple times to come to
Britain and to give us these answers and
every single time he's refused and you
have to wonder why because what I
another journalist have uncovered is
that multiple crimes took place during
the referendum and they took place on
Facebook it's because in Britain we
limit the amount of money that you can
spend in an election and it's because in
the 19th century people would walk
around like literally wheelbarrows of
cash and just by voters so we passed
these strict laws to stop that from
happening but those laws don't work
anymore this referendum took place
almost entirely online and you can spend
any amount of money on Facebook or on
Google or on YouTube and so nobody will
know because they're black boxes and
this is what happened we've actually got
no idea of the full extent of it but we
do know that in the last days before the
brexit vote the official vote leave
campaign laundered three nearly
three-quarters of a million pounds
through another campaign entity that our
Electoral Commission has ruled was
illegal and it's referred it to the
police and with this illegal cash vote
leaves unleashed a firehose of
disinformation ads like this this is a
lie it's a total lie
turkey is not joining the European Union
there's not even any discussions of it
joining the European Union and most of
us we never saw these ads because we
were not the target of them don't leave
identified a tiny sliver of people who
had identified as persuadable and they
saw them and the only reason we are
seeing these now is because Parliament
forced Facebook to hand them over and
maybe you think well it was just a bit
of overspending
it's a few lies but this was the biggest
electoral fraud in Britain for a hundred
years in a once-in-a-generation vote
they're hinged upon just one percent of
the electorate and it was just one of
the crimes that took place in the
referendum there was another group which
was headed by this man Nigel Farage the
one to the right of Trump and his group
levy you it also broke the law it also
it broke British electoral laws and
British data laws and it's also being
referred to the police and this man
Aaron Banks he funded this campaign and
in a completely separate case he's been
referred to them at our National Crime
Agency our equivalents of the FBI
because our Electoral Commission has
concluded they don't know where his
money came from or if it was even
British and I'm not even going to go
into the lies that Aaron banks has told
about his covert relationship with the
Russian government or the weird timing
of Nigel Farage's meetings with Julian
Assange and with Trump's buddy Roger
stone now indicted immediately before
two massive wiki leak dumps both of
which haven't have benefit Donald
Trump's but I will tell you that brexit
and trunk were intimately entwined this
man told me that bricks it was the petri
dish for Trump and we know it's the same
people the same companies the same data
the same techniques the same use of hate
and fear this is what they were posting
on Facebook and I do you want to call
this a lie because it feels more like a
hate crime to me I don't have to tell
you that hate and fear are being sown
online all across the world not just in
Britain or in America but in France and
in Hungary and Brazil and mine Mar and
New Zealand and we know that
his dark undertow which is connecting us
all globally and it is flowing via the
technology platforms but we only see a
tiny amount of what's going on on the
surface and I only found out anything
about this dark underbelly because I
started looking into Trump's
relationship to Faraj to a company
called Cambridge analytical and I spent
months tracking down an ex-employee
Christopher Wylie and he told me how
this company that worked for both Trump
and brexit had profiled people
politically in order to understand their
individual fears to better target them
with Facebook Ads and it did this by
illicit ly harvesting the profiles of 87
million people from Facebook it took an
entire year's work to get Christopher on
the record and I had to turn myself from
a feature writer into an investigative
reporter to do it and he was
extraordinarily brave because the
company is owned by Robert Mercer the
billionaire who bankrolled Trump and he
threatened to sue us multiple times to
stop us from publishing but we finally
got there and we were one day ahead of
publication we got another legal threat
not from Cambridge annalistic er this
time but from Facebook it told us that
if we publish they would sue us we did
it anyway
Facebook you were on the wrong side of
history in that and you were on the
wrong side of history in this in
refusing to give us the answers that we
need and that is why I am here to
address you directly the gods of Silicon
Valley and Sheryl Sandberg and Larry
Page and Sergey Brin and Jack Dorsey and
your employees and your investors too
because a hundred years ago the biggest
danger in the South Wales coal mines was
gasps silent and deadly and invisible
it's why they sent the Canaries down
first to check the air and in this
massive global online experiment that we
are all at living through we in Britain
are the canary we are what happens to a
Western democracy when a hundred years
of electoral laws are disrupted by
technology our democracy is broken our
laws don't work anymore and it's not me
saying this it's our Parliament
published a report saying this this
technology that you have invented has
been amazing but now it's a crime scene
and you have the evidence and it is not
enough to say that you will do better in
the future
because to have any hope of stopping
this from happening again
we have to know the truth
and maybe you think well it was just a
few ads and people are smarter than that
right to which I would say good luck
with that because what the brexit vote
demonstrates is that liberal democracy
is broken and you broke it this is not
democracy spreading lies in darkness
paid for with illegal cash from God
knows where
it's subversion and you are accessories
to it
our Parliament has been the first in the
world to try to hold you to account and
it's failed you are literally beyond the
reach of British law not just British
laws this is nine Parliament's nine
countries are represented here who Mark
Zuckerberg refused to come and give
evidence to and what you don't seem to
understand is that this is bigger than
you and it's bigger than any of us and
it is not about left or right or leave
or remain or Trump or not it's about
whether it's actually possible to have a
free and fair election ever again
because as it stands I don't think it is
and so my question to you is is this
what you want is this how you want
history to remember you as the
handmaidens to authoritarianism that is
on the rise all across the world because
you set out to connect people and you
are refusing to acknowledge that the
same technology is now driving us apart
and my question to everybody else is is
this what we want to let them get away
with it and to sit back and play with
our phones there's this darkness falls
the history of the South Wales Valleys
is of a fight for rights and this is not
a drill it's a point of inflection
democracy is not guaranteed and it is
not inevitable and we have to fight and
we have to win and we cannot let these
tech companies have this unchecked power
it's up to us you me in all of us we are
the ones you have to take back control
[Applause]